-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Democratic senator
Raphael Warnock
is projected to defeat
Republican candidate
Herschel Walker
in the Georgia Senate
runoff race.
And if you think
you're relieved,
imagine how relieved
Herschel Walker is.
He just narrowly avoided
a six-year-long pop quiz
he did not study for.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
CNN last night projected
that Georgia senator
Raphael Warnock
will win reelection.
And then Herschel Walker picked
up an iron to call and concede.
[ Laughter ]
The Trump Organization
was found guilty yesterday
in a New York court
for criminal tax fraud.
Trump will be sentenced
to four years as president.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded -- Though --
[ Laughter ]
Always something wrong
with the syntax of the joke.
For me.
It was written fine.
Let's do it one more time.
Sorry, Baze.
You know what
the worst thing is?
Our head writer
is allowed to fire me.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded for --
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. How dare you?!
My name's on the door!
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to try.
Alright.
"Though it succeeded
for so long..."
Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
"Though it..."
"Though it succeeded for..."
Okay.
"Though it succeeded..."
This better work.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
a Manhattan jury yesterday
found former President Trump's
company guilty
of orchestrating a 15-year
criminal tax fraud scheme.
Though it succeeded for so long,
there's no way Trump
had anything to do with it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We got to have a rehearsal
from now on.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
visited Arizona yesterday
for the first time
in his presidency.
Said Biden, "Wow, the last time
I was here, this was all flat."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Baze, you know what?
I'm going to turn the tables.
That joke makes
no [bleep] sense.
Can you go back?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they all laughed
'cause he's an old man, ha-ha.
But...
President Biden
visited Arizona yesterday
for the first time
in his presidency.
So, like, for the first time
in two years.
That meant three years ago,
he was probably there.
Why was it flat then?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe if it was like "for the
first time since he was a kid,"
then the joke works.
'Cause he's so old.
You know what I'm saying?
I just want to make something
clear to all of you.
We're all doing a bad job.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I will make this same speech
at the Christmas party!
[ Laughter ]
During last week's
White House state dinner,
French president Emmanuel Macron
reportedly toasted to President
Biden's reelection campaign.
Either that or Biden said
he was running again
and Macron
just started drinking.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday
encouraged Americans
to get updated
coronavirus vaccine shots
ahead of the holidays,
if for no other reason
than Santa's 2,000 years old.
[ Light laughter ]
Is that Scol?
Who wrote that?
Scollins?
Scollins wrote that joke.
He's one of our writers
who doesn't like people.
And what he wanted in the key
was Santa on a ventilator.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
That's just hearing it.
That's the reaction you make
when you hear it.
He wanted to show it to you.
[ Laughter ]
New York's annual SantaCon
bar crawl is this weekend,
and more than 60 bars
are expected to participate,
as well as several local jails.
[ Laughter ]
BuzzFeed announced plans
yesterday
to lay off roughly 180 staffers.
Even worse,
the way they announced it.
[ Laughter ]
Oy, somebody put Santa on
a ventilator with that joke.
[ Laughter ]
Ben & Jerry's
announced yesterday
they will release a new flavor
curated by director
Ava DuVernay.
Meanwhile, the
James Cameron-inspired flavor
is currently 10 years behind
and $200 million over budget.
[ Laughter ]
Regulators in Minnesota
this week
accused
a marijuana edibles company
of selling gummy bears that were
50 times more powerful
than what is legally
allowed to be sold.
This actually happened
last year,
but all the witnesses
just woke up.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
just 2% of Americans said
that they never felt happy
when someone they like
succeeds at something.
Or as they put it on Instagram,
"Oh, my God,
I love that for you."
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.